hello readers today i'd like to talk to
you about the moral of the story
which story well we'll we'll get to that
first what is a moral it's a lesson
usually about how you're supposed to
treat other people i think we can say
that if a story has a moral it's trying
to teach you how to be a good person
esop's fables are full of these there's
the story of the tortoise and the hare
which i'll tell you very quickly if
you're unfamiliar the slow-moving
tortoise and the speedy hair have a foot
race and the hair is so sure that she'll
beat the tortoise that she stops to take
a nap during the race meanwhile the
tortoise slowly and steadily continues
onwards and crosses the finish line
while the hare is sleeping that's
confetti as the tortoise crosses the
finish line the moral of the story is
slow and steady wins the race you can
beat an overconfident person even if
they're more talented than you if you
try really hard and take it slow but
steady
but it's not just old stories from
ancient greece that have morals the
stories around us are full of lessons
about how to treat one another so how do
you figure out what the moral of a story
is good question one way to do it is to
ask yourself what the problem of the
story is or how the problem was solved
from the hare's perspective the problem
in the tortoise and the hair is that she
lost the race
what could she have done to avoid that
happening well she probably shouldn't
have stopped to take a nap from the
tortoise's perspective the problem is
solved he won the race and how did he do
that by maintaining a slow steady pace
for the whole race
and then you take that lesson that the
characters learned and you say okay so
this is true for everyone
it's not just that hairs should make
sure not to nap during foot races it's
that people who are good at stuff
shouldn't get so confident about their
skills that they don't try as hard the
hair is really good at running quickly
so she thinks she doesn't need to try so
hard against a tortoise because that is
what morals do they are lessons in
stories that we can apply to our lives
what's true for the hair and what's true
for the tortoise are true for you and me
because those stories were invented to
teach people stories not just tortoises
and hairs
you can learn anything
dave it out